[Music]
the following video is a sample from my
new online classical guitar course sign
up this memorial day weekend to get 40
off
let's learn another piece now with this
p i alternation technique this is mela
genia
a piece which we're going to play
for our ending recital of this course
with this piece i find it's easier to
first memorize
and learn the
melody which is in the bass voice
actually the lower voice
played with all with the thumb
so let's walk through that very slowly
the first two measures are the same
thing twice
and notice that my left hand doesn't
move so the left hand stays still on the
notes e and g sharp and we make sure
that we have very curled fingers playing
on the tips that the b string
is sounding and doesn't sound
muted
so let's get really good at this the
first two measures ready go
we'll just keep doing this for a while
make sure i can hear all the notes
i'm playing strings four three two four
three two all with the thumb three
strokes
[Music]
i think that's not too hard actually the
next two bars gives us a more
interesting melody with the thumb in the
right hand we have
a c b
a g
f
and then the third measure i think we
can just leave our middle finger down
the whole time actually
so the middle finger can just stay down
so that it's there for the next measure
and then open
third finger on
f let's just practice those last two
measures ready
go
[Music]
make sure you're using the thumb on the
right hand all right now all four
measures ready go
[Music]
repeat
[Music]
my recommendation is to play this until
you have it memorized which shouldn't
take you too long actually and that'll
make this song a lot easier to play now
assuming that's going well i like you to
add your index finger plucking between
each note
but your mind is focusing on the lower
notes
your index finger is on autopilot
so that's going to be the first section
of this piece and then in the second
section i've decided to treat you guys
to a special fun technique on the guitar
which is strumming it's so fun to strum
on the guitar it feels so natural that i
felt obligated to show you guys a little
bit of scrubbing to do this we have to
learn our first chord
chords remember are just when we play
multiple notes at the same time to do
this we're going to use this little
diagram here this is how we write
chord symbols on the guitar it shows you
where to put each finger
that's actually kind of often the
easiest way to learn a chord or you can
look at the tab here and eventually you
just memorize the shape so this first
chord we're going to learn is e
or e major if you just see the letter e
that does mean e major so we have our
index finger down on g sharp
we have our ring finger on
the e on the fourth string and we have a
middle finger
on the fifth string second fret now
again make sure that all these fingers
are playing on the tips of the fingers
very round very curved
fingers if you play with flat fingers
here this chord will sound
awful if that's you it's because your
your hand looks like this make your hand
more
like that
nice and curved as much as possible try
to scoot your fingers to the right side
of the fret so make sure the index
finger is all the way on the right
the ring finger is playing all the way
on the right and your middle finger has
to play above on the same fret as your
ring finger but see if you can squeeze
those fingers one on top of each other
and that'll make for a really good
sounding e major chord if all your
fingers look like they're ready you can
test it take your thumb p in the right
hand and just drag it
through all the strings down towards the
floor
should have made a great sound even if
it's a little buzzy it sounds so cool
so if it's a little buzzy don't worry
about it for now we're gonna keep
playing so we have two strums on e major
so
we're just dragging our thumb through
the strings leave your thumb kind of
stiff and drag your arm
down you can use nail
or you can use the flesh
they both sound really good by the way
that squiggly line with an arrow going
up is the symbol for strumming
so after you strum twice down down we're
then going to slap
the top of the guitar yes i give you
permission to slap your guitar lightly
don't don't break it just
a light a light slap on top of the
guitar so we have town down slap let's
do this on repeat ready go down down
slap down down slap down down slap down
down slap i don't know about you but i
think this is super fun
okay so then take that e major chord
which you have in your left hand and
what you're going to do now is scoot the
whole thing to the right one fret leave
everything it was but just scoot
everything to the right
one fret you can look at the tab here if
you're confused uh and then leave your
fingers down and do the same thing in
the right hand down down slap this is a
fantastic gorgeous
flamenco cord
it's very distant and very spicy now
from here we're going to drag your
fingers up two frets so one
two leave all the fingers down just
where they were like in the e major
chord shape we strum again down down
slap so that was e major
and you slide your fingers up one
you slide your fingers up two
next we go backwards so back down two
and then we strum
back to the first chord e
once you've done the slap part that down
down slap down down slap then we just
strum each chord once again but the same
pattern
[Music]
just like that so the strumming
variation will sound like this all
together ready go
[Music]
so
[Music]
i hope everyone's enjoying today's
guitar tip just a reminder that today's
video is just one of 53 videos that make
up my six hour course this is a beginner
online classical guitar course meant to
help you fall in love with the elegant
sounds of the classical guitar check out
the link in the description to learn
more but for now back to the video so
the way my version of melee genia works
is you play the melee genius theme
twice
and then we strum
[Music]
back to the plucking theme
i'm playing fast i know
one more time the slapping variation
[Music]
and to end we have a really beautiful
harp-like arpeggio to play this leave
your fingers on an e major chord in the
left hand and we're just going to drag
your thumb through the strings one
two
three
one
two
three so all the fingers stay down for
the first two measures one two three one
two
three
and notice also i wrote a couple things
first of all to hold all those notes
don't move your left hand all the notes
should be ringing the second is i wrote
this kind of reverse alligator mouth
this line that's getting closer and
closer together that's a decrescendo
crescendo means to
um get louder gradually and decrescendo
is the opposite
gradually get softer so the six notes
from the end is one
two
three
four
five
six
gradually getting softer i also wrote
the word writ which is ritardando to get
slower so it's one two three
four
five
six
and to finish the piece a very beautiful
crystalline
sparkly harmonic harmonics are like
beautiful little bells
on the guitar
they work really well in the 12th fret
the seventh
and
the fifth
so to play our harmonic go to the 12th
fret on the first string and what i want
you to do is touch over the metal where
you're not supposed to play usually not
in the good spot but on top of the metal
now don't push down at all
with the weight of a fly touch the
string and touch the string with a flat
of your finger not the tip like normal
and after you pluck take your hand away
and you should get a beautiful bell
that's a harmonic so the very end sounds
like this
[Music]
[Laughter]
so this is a big piece i packed a lot of
stuff into this one
but let's give the whole thing a try a
little bit under tempo please do adjust
the gear icon to match the speed to your
current plane level but for now here we
go one two three
again
now we strum down down slap
[Music]
written above that means we can hold it
for a while
next page ready go
strong
[Music]
long strums
and to end the big arpeggio
[Music]
this is a piece that sounds good really
at any tempo because it's so idiomatic
it fits so well on the guitar and the
classical tar is indeed such a spanish
instrument in origin that for me this
really sounds so
natural on the instrument i hope you're
having fun with it
today's video was just a small sample
for my new online classical guitar
course click on the link in the
description to get instant lifetime
access to this six hour classical atari
course
[Music]
you